this stained glass ceiling is impressive
and opulent but where does it exist in
the drone overhead shot for shame show
this isn't the same house immigration
revenue is it possible someone in the
history of cra visits has said revenue
instead of cra sure it is canada after
all does it sound stupid enough to still
sit it also sure and how exactly did all
these agents get here there were only
two cars in the driveway when we saw
that overhead shot john i've been
stripped of every morsel of pleasure i
earned in this life i mean earn seems
like a strong word if the cra is out
there taking all your rich people watch
movies tv shows and music videos all
week for a living and then tell me how
hard your week has been eli was family
for god's sake leave your finances to me
said son of a [ __ ] well the son of a
[ __ ] part should have been a dead
getaway not to trust him um phrasing
baby it's crazy people are just like
taking our stuff
i said they're taking our stuff can you
just step out of the club for a second
keeping up with the canadians i'm still
trying to wrap my mind where i'm a kind
of a sick person wants to get paid to
destroy another person's life geez all
we do is poke fun at tv shows it's
nothing personal oh they were talking
about the cra weren't they carry on also
i would like to point out that david is
two arms deep and pearl necklaces don't
really have a good reason just felt like
it needed to be set where are you taking
that where is anyone taking anything
some agents are going further into the
house some are going to the other side
of the home some down the stairs and
around the corner and this way and that
what is anyone doing like they yelled
action and everyone scattered until they
hit a prop lifted the prop and scurried
back the other way like confused
kleptomaniac mall walkers one asset the
government has allowed you to retain the
kids the children are dependents moira
until the age of 22 and then they are no
longer dependents they are moochers
these adult-sized children are
absolutely moochers why would i
photoshop a deed the joke was owning the
town there's a brilliant scene in north
by northwest where cary grant and james
mason first meet and the whole sequence
feels like an excuse to have a
classically trained theater actor
explain to a hollywood movie star what
real acting is all about this scene
feels very much like an older and much
funnier comedian explaining to an
up-and-comer how jokes work which
reminds me that i hate millennials
photoshop the
deed off holy can i say [ __ ] oh this is
going to be fun thank you for this gift
daniel levy i don't know what to tell
you there's like cows all over the place
rich kids down the mirror so if you're
looking for a nasty kiss it's mine chris
elliot should know all about that he
kissed david letterman's ass all the way
to a career that has now been spanning
five decades i mean i like cabin boy as
much as the next idiot with terrible
taste in movies but five goddamn decades
you shut up you shut up um do you shut
up how about we just scoop up we'll need
three rooms minimum ooh no can do honey
look we have a one room com policy here
you do what does that even mean this
isn't vegas they own the goddamn town
and they can't get three rooms in a very
vacant motel what the [ __ ] you know i
did the deed in just about every room in
this place then what idiot lost to
roland in this town's mayoral race i
thought sorted motel sexcapades didn't
get people elected in canada what the
[ __ ] is happening on this screen the
second to last column has a two of clubs
which means this should be a three of
hearts and it clearly isn't because the
three of hearts is here also why is
every black card a club i suppose this
is possible but if you're going to go
through the trouble to photoshop an
impossible game couldn't you at least
try for a four suit setup absolutely
necessary yes that train has left the
station if you know what i mean yep
everyone knows what roland means man for
a show that prides itself on cutting
edge humor and cast comedy legends like
levy and o'hara they still aren't
beneath the sexer joke every now and
then and that's a but unfortunate
because if someone were to break in here
in the middle of the night wanting to
murder us they would attack this bed
first and then what would you do would
you just run away and leave me to bleed
out on the floor technically if you were
murdered in your bed you'd bleed out in
your bed
you never heard first well if they can
hear that this clearly they could hear
this i'm waiting for the right
opportunity okay otherwise dad's gonna
cry and mom's gonna do that thing or she
so they should already know about
alexis's plan to leave and she doesn't
need to tell them later was the door
open the entire time sure there's a
possibility that this family is so
wealthy they can't fathom the importance
of not heating or air conditioning the
neighborhood and therefore wouldn't even
notice an open door but they would be
terrified of bugs and the permeating
scent of dung on a cow-laden breeze we
have to eat in here nope you can eat or
starve whoa i sound like my mom she'll
be so proud
this angle shows alexis's menu unfold
over the side of the table which is
impossible considering she's been shown
to be directly against the wall let's
say for comedy sake a motel would
advertise they have push button phones
i'm still sending the fact that they
forgot a dash between push and button
and then inserted an unnecessary one in
tv these rooms did have doors didn't
they it's a hotel they're hotel rooms
it's a motel these are motel rooms i
know david is supposed to be annoying
but holy [ __ ] i just want to kick the
[ __ ] out of him every time he opens his
mouth is stevie still playing the same
solitaire game oh no i see she somehow
managed to move the nine of hearts from
the left column directly onto the six of
clubs from the previous scene shit's
creek solitaire is
[ __ ] it looks like them
seeing catherine o'hara embrace this
eccentric role as the highlight of this
pilot for me take a sin back you crazy
legend
oh
hello
hello
moira accuses stevie of stealing her
diamonds and clearly this baffles her
mind so intensely that she forgets the
original direction she was walking and
sort of wanders back the other way poor
stevie she may never find her car
someone got in here and stole my
earrings which reminds me how would the
tax agents allow this family to keep all
their expensive jewelry if everything of
value was seized wouldn't their rings
and necklaces have been taken moira
indicates she had to hide her diamonds
under her tongue so is this costume
jewelry david could you help me with the
doors it's air drying maybe i'm wrong
but wouldn't air drying work anywhere
there was air let's all pray we don't
wake up you know one problem is with not
waking up you will all eventually [ __ ]
yourselves yeah i could do this all
night
okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay
there's a family
oh that's not right i would rather talk
about
[Applause]
gretchen thinks you're mad at her
because she's running for spring fling
queen
look
i am in desperate need of assistance
hell well well what's on your mind
little girl i realize that you are most
likely the product of lower class
inbreeding but perhaps you could help me
goodnight children goodnight mama not
ben goodnight everyone good night mama
night daddy goodnight children good
night daddy good night elizabeth
goodnight tomboy